catherine hill épidémiologiste bonsoir
catherine hill merci d'être en direct
avec mon sur rt france pékin qui referme
dans toutes les écoles de la ville qui
appelle ses habitants à ne pas quitter
la métropole
quelle est votre réaction est ce qu on
assiste clairement à une résurgence à
une deuxième vague nous c'est un peu
prématuré de s'exprimer ainsi
je pense que c'est prématuré c'est
effectivement l'arrêt la une arrive et
nouvelles du virus dans la apk parce
qu'il y avait pas eu de cas depuis
longtemps et tout d'un coup il ya eu on
a fait à peu près 30 diagnostic chaque
jour dans les trois derniers jours
quelque chose comme ça à peu près mais
les chinois font ça très sérieusement et
il teste massivement la population et
j'ai comparé le nombre de cas rapportés
à la population de pékin qui est de 22
millions et 34 30 cas par jour pour ban
de millions de personnes
c'est moins que le nombre de cartes
qu'on a en france chaque jour dans les
trois derniers jours
on en a à peu près trois ou quatre fois
plus donc c'est pas en france on a des
confiné tout le monde
on teste on continue à tester très très
peu de gens puisque on fait moins de la
moitié des 700 mille tests qui sont
disponibles chaque semaine donc les
chinois prennent la chose beaucoup plus
sérieusement que nous l optimiser tri
d'une certaine manière ce n'est pas plus
qu'un cluster en france
non mais je parle pas de jets papa de
chaque cluster en france je parle du
nombre de cas en france
au total chaque jour pour l'ensemble de
la population de 65 millions en france
métropolitaine
il ya plus de cas pour les 65 millions
de français de france métropolitaine ya
plus de cas chaque jour qu'il n'y en a à
pékin depuis trois jours ou où on voit
une résurgence du virus
il était arrivé à un état beaucoup de
contamination bien plus faible que nous
et ils sont revenus à un niveau qui est
plus bien plus faible que celui que nous
avons aujourd'hui alors ce que tu peux
frapper catherine il sait que
un nouveau un marché alimentaire est
soupçonné on a quand même le sentiment
depuis la france que l'histoire se
répète
vous nous dites ici voilà vous êtes la
deuxième invitée nous dire voilà les
autorités chinoises on peut compter sur
l aide c'est sous contrôle mais voilà
toujours ses problèmes de marché que
peut-on faire que peut-on suggérer aux
chinois si on peut leur suggérer quelque
chose c'est pas à nous de leur suggérer
grille mais c'est à nous deux c'est à
eux de nous expliquer comment ils ont
fait pour éviter par exemple que le
virus n'arrive à pékin auparavant ils
ont vraiment très très bien manoeuvré là
les premiers première épidémie a été
très très largement confinée à roubaix à
la province de omrane et il ya eu très
peu de cas à pékin il ya eu neuf morts
en tout à pékin
donc jusqu'ici se sont très bien
débrouillés donc on va leur faire
confiance ils savent très bien se
débrouiller et je constate qu'en france
on continue à ne pas tester massivement
la population à oignies à lui de nouveau
quelques cas et ils ont testé 11
millions de personnes en dix jours et
nous on fait pas assez de test il faut
trouver les gens qui sont porteurs du
virus et qui en contamine d'autres et il
y en a en france tout le temps puisqu'il
ya des nouveaux foyers comptant
aujourd'hui clairement est ce qu un
scénario similaire est possible en
france où dit on continue à ne pas
tester est ce qu on pourrait craindre
précisément justement plus que des
petits foyers localisés mais
une deuxième année en raison de ce
manque de tester vous dites souvent sur
ce plateau en raison peut-être d'un
manque de rigueur sur le port de masques
notamment
mais s'il ya 300 nouveaux cas chaque
jour en france et on nous raconte
quelques quelques foyers mais on nous
raconte pas où sont tous les cas et on
nous raconte pas les cas dans les ehpad
on nous raconte pas les cas
asymptomatiques qu'ils restent chez eux
et qu'ils sont pas diagnostiqués donc je
pense que le problème en france est
sous-estimé est sous diagnostiquée
aujourd'hui qu'elle peut être justement
l'attitude des autorités
vous dites c'est sous-estimer
sous-diagnostiquée ça veut dire qu'on
nous cacherait volontiers volontairement
plutôt des choses ou tout simplement
voilà on est passé à autre chose à l'est
près épidémie peut-être un peu trop vite
oui en effet c'est à dire qu'on en sait
plus penchés sur le problème économique
sur le problème sanitaire et on n'a pas
pris la mesure du problème qui est que
la moitié des contaminations viennent de
gens qui sont pas symptomatique donc ils
se savent pas contaminants donc si on ne
cherche pas les porteurs asymptomatiques
est la seule façon de les trouver c'est
de faire des tests systématiquement dans
la population qui n'a pas de symptômes
alors l'épidémie continue c'est ce qu'on
voit non c'est vrai que c'est un bruit
c'est vrai que olivier verrons nous
avait dit voilà on a des tests 700
milles mais on va pas les utiliser parce
que aujourd'hui l'épidémie est en recul
il a dit ça il ya quelques jours alors
on précise quand même que jérôme salomon
entre temps nous est quand même préciser
que l'épidémie était loin d'être
terminée c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion de la part parfois des
autorités on a du mal à voir clair il
faut regarder combien il ya de nouveaux
cas chaque jour c'est sur le site du
gouvernement tout le monde peut aller
regarder et il y en a encore et un peu
partout donc le virus continue à
circuler
le fait qu'il y ait tous les jours une
baisse des chiffres en réanimation une
baisse de chiffre
voilà des décès fort heureusement et
d'admissions dans les hôpitaux est ce
que tout le même
ça veut dire que c'est bon signe parce
que la courbe ne cesse de descendre sas
s'abaisse pas vraiment c'est quasi
constant et puis tous les mardis on
rajoute les décès dans les ehpad donc on
va voir demain enfin en fait mercredi
les données du mardi sorte et on voit
toujours un petit rebond
donc ça descend par vraiment c'est assez
stable ses attraits l'apidémie continuer
à très très bas bruit très très
doucement
le virus n'a pas disparu merci catherine
hill épidémiologiste d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france